suena la alarma en francia ante los
rebrotes de comida el gobierno señala
que hay un innegable resurgimiento de la
epidemia con 39 casos positivos por cada
100.000 habitantes es decir cuatro veces
más que hace un mes se achica estos
indicadores muestran que la epidemia
está recuperando terreno y yutong
segmento y que ahora es el momento de
intervenir o al menos de seguir
interviniendo masivamente ante a venir
máximo incontestable y sin duda algo ha
estado sucediendo desde este verano en
francia y en otros lugares que los
científicos no necesariamente habían o
modelado o previsto
entre las nuevas medidas que son castex
ha anunciado están 19 de los 101
departamentos del país pasan a zona roja
sumándose a dos regiones que ya estaban
en esta clasificación
una medida que autoriza a los gobiernos
locales a imponer nuevas restricciones
en parís a partir de este viernes será
obligatorio llevar mascarilla por toda
la ciudad
anunció que el uso de mascarillas pasa a
ser obligatorio en todas las escuelas de
francia por otra parte el ministro de
salud de lidia de ajo habló de la
capacidad de pruebas del país como de un
arma importante junto a rastrear y
aislar yo hablé con los laboratorios
ayer y fije un objetivo a corto plazo de
un millón de pruebas por semana estamos
entre los diez primeros tal vez entre
los ocho primeros y queremos ir más allá
de eso lo que queremos hacer es que las
pruebas estén disponibles para todos los
que las necesitan y todos los que las
quieren virus suites
ante esta situación aunque aztecs llamó
a los franceses a más prevención en el
caso de que las cifras no se mejoren el
ejecutivo ha preparado varios planes de
reconocimiento a nivel local y global
aunque no preferiría llegar a este punto